понад 170 тисяч дітей по всій Україні та
вид права їх у магніту бурим у межах
руку англійську нова приголомшена
президентом такі протитум мистецтво
продажів черні взялася про або вшиту
знання та чиновники як саме дарина
шпортко розповість
шляхів групі слова забути танцям
це speakon будь ми річкова софія пояс
її чому в трохи англійській чим можна
було загнати та за core duo міша тому та
обидва рази милі нч і люди щоб можна
було поїсти в ресторані і тицяв по цій
особі та нею магазині і до монстра та
яблуку був прикладом морозову
кіно це і тут ой spain дали за
витратою урок трудового навчання
vintage розплачується з пісні будемо
pleats пластилін відвари ніг
битва звістка про всю групу на заняття
дід обирають бутерброд у-син градієнти
англійську в такому бурі вкотре повідають
в оклади че акцент роблять самий на
спинку вані зміни всієї піт хіт на зараз
мало іноземного і chaiti також які видно
все в уроці цех ж групи з формування
заливним c можливо хоч і багато уроків
на змі волосся з теми про таких зайняти але
таких скажемо скажемо про клуб
як я вже сказала klups спилку вання
імена квіти здаються го року шкільних
модних то булевів україні бьякуя тисяч
загальна кілька дітей кобудо брат і
долею таких таборах становить
вимови
170000 зовсім